puis est arrivée la
première fracture entre la
technostructure et les soignants à
savoir que nous pensions vraiment qu'il
allait y avoir un monde d'après
au moins pour la santé or dès le 11 mai
nos bureaucrates sont revenus avec leurs
petits tableaux de bord pour reprendre
les plans d'économie là où les états
et selon les propres statistiques du
ministère cinq mille 700 lits ont été
fermés en 2020 nous sommes le seul pays
au monde à avoir fermé des lits en
période et qu'une épidémie pour des
raisons économiques
la deuxième fracture ça a été la
décision de la rue du refus de
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle des soignants victimes
du coc vide
85000 à l'hôpital cinquante cinq mille
autres dans les ehpad au 26 novembre 21
1690 dossiers ont été reconnus par les
caisses primaires
la troisième fracture c'est le ségur
avec
d'une part pour un certain nombre de
soignants
183 euros qui était loin des
attentes des professionnels et qui
montre le décalage qu'il y à encore
aujourd'hui entre eux le salaire
infirmiers moyens européens et ce qui a
été fait par par le gouvernement et puis
surtout tous ces oubliés du ségur avec
mois après mois on en rajoute un peu par
ci on en rajoute un peu par là le
sentiment qu'il ya des soignants plus ou
moins investi le plus ou moins méritant
etc
[Musique]